what's with the jeans don't bring anyone
she ain't here it wasn't for your mother
you wouldn't be here remember when you
put down one mother you put down mothers
all over the world we are here today as
for mommies
everybody say hello to mr. Tom Segura hi
mommy
the dance champion red that's me we have
a special guest and the moms house
now you might know Matt Braunger he's a
stand-up comedian he was on MADtv very
famous and ronger what what other things
would people know you from oh boy I
could tell you I know okay yeah usual do
it I've seen you on the David Letterman
Show oh wow making stand-ups mm-hmm I've
seen you telling skits of jokes on you
saw you did The Tonight Show with Conan
I did you got to get in that window that
window
it's pretty awesome yeah really awesome
yeah and you've also done pushing up
daisies pushing daisies yes on there
um rimjob Tuesdays and Jase yeah I'm a
guest host a lot of times and I mostly
just stand there go look at what that
guys doing it that guy does he know
that's not a girl and they're all boning
around him yeah it it's got I think at
last count four point nine million
subscribers Wow excellent and wait what
else cuz I know I'm leaving out stuff
because we want everyone to know how
wonderful you are I think I did a little
thing on United States of Tara I was on
the Halloween episode of iCarly my star
and did a special half-hour special last
year year before you Oh excellent oh
wait a minute forgetting stuff because
there's so many things that we can't get
to them all no that's embarrassing
festivals and clubs in college shitload
of commercials too right yeah I feel
like I've always seen I see Bob you know
I stopped doing him in like 2008 or
something but before that yeah I was I
was pretty steadily not even like not
one that we're like oh so much money but
just wanted to just they show a lot oh
yeah like a crap deal I get like
flat-rate and we'll show it to your ad
but yeah that's a car now
you don't mind telling sharing with us
where did you just come from right now
just now yeah the dentist the dentist
yes it's been it's been a real issue
which changes to a dental podcast
what's wrong my molar we did like a 20
minute segment fillings shit I feel bad
for anybody listening let's talk about
it more now how are your teeth cool
yeah I might the bone structure of my
skull is very dense about my teeth that
pushes them kind of together so it's
hard harder for me to floss and stuff
yeah they told me get like an electric
toothbrush yeah some not Waterpik but
just like just like where those little
oral bees or you know did you already
know you had dense bones hey you know
it's not like new I knew I liked nice
too I had braces and all that all that
stuff but uh so I guess that's why but
yeah I didn't know I had
cro-magnon skull teeth are so important
you're right a joke about that
millionaires yeah joke the thing is that
people rightfully so get obsessed about
teeth in a way that wasn't even possible
before yeah I mean I don't think yeah I
don't think 40 years ago you could be
like I want my teeth to look like this
now like specifically like but people
still fuck it up is the amazing part you
look at some famous people's teeth and
it looks like like billboards right shit
and like clearly it hasn't been
perfected like Steve Harvey's got like
well if shark if sharks had teeth like
ours that's how they would look straight
not sharp you know just for eating
sandwiches not you know but they're
never good the veneer thing they never
you never look at them and go that looks
really good well in natural the plate
the place I I've been going to is kind
of fancy yeah you know it's like unless
you have insurance like monuments all
dentists offices cost than mostly the
same so it's just like you know going
twice a year or whatever but like I can
see how like they're doing veneers and
replacing all the stuff has made them so
wealthy like where I'm sitting in my
chair I'm over
jingling all this majestic part of a
landfill golf courses and stuff yeah
remember how Denis officers used to be
weird kids like it's a step above a
mechanic's officer yeah sit down
just sit down you know I just gotta hold
you down with his shoulders well you
just you know pulls it - there's nothing
yeah wasn't even just like shut up
x-rays they put the lead cloth on you
and then they puncture your gums with
those stupid remember that was a film
that was scraping this five years ago is
this a deck of cards that you've been
into yeah mine too like mine has one of
those like sharper image chairs where do
you sit down and I think they have like
a heated massage thing going on and they
also have a remote control for this LCD
screen that's like sitting there and
there never was like that when you're
you know you can watch television before
you know I to use my brain pull back on
x-rays either like you remember like
they would be like we're gonna give you
27 x-rays right when we all turned like
20 they're like you know you shouldn't
really get that many x-rays
really it's really like that that
Simpsons where Milhouse is is
radioactive man's sidekick our Fall Out
Boy and then just she's like under
something energy shooting it with like
great question
keep going I was watching a Conan last
night and you have this big HDTV in the
other room and one thing I noticed they
were shaving his beard off in this
episode as a big thing or whatever but
he has veneers I think because his teeth
was so close because they're shaving
this part of the beard and it was just
perfect team it is kind of weird that
nothing have you seen a veneer procedure
done have you seen Oh
really hard they shave your teeth in the
baby teeth have you removed
everyone's veneers find out like veneers
cause cancer taking off immediately
everyone's gonna have these crazy teeth
I have porcelain fronts I have two big
front teeth and they're all my dentist
you really gotta get the veneer I'm like
no dude there's no way you're gonna
shave down what I do have left cuz
you're right in ten years they're gonna
be like guess what yeah veneers make
your asshole bleed and then you just
clench your ass I sensed it yeah I have
a psychic ability to sense his fart
since the claim that you puckered yeah
they still use those red things at the
dentist where you chew on and it shows
where you didn't brush that's like some
breast cancer thing that they just kind
of took off the red dye ninety-nine on
it yeah and you'd have like the dental
day in elementary school and they give
you like a handful of them and then you
do it for like a day we're really good
and I never fought yeah we talked about
this can we talk about what happened
well Casey Abrams got voted off American
Idol devastating okay good teeth that
guy well in the other little story about
we got him oh so what is everyone's like
Osama bin gotta mow sauna up stahma been
gotten Laden Mike burns are the best
quote he's like he's like look man it's
it it's like wrestling fans out there
right now yeah like let's just come
that's like yeah okay it's good did that
happen you basically shot an old man in
the face yeah an old man was shot in the
face rad terrible old man yeah someone's
who deserve that but you know it's like
I don't know but
I tell you that I'm really annoyed when
like I'm as liberal as they come but the
night it happened in Silverlake in our
and our hipster neighborhood Matt also
lives in yep I went to a restaurant and
I gladly told the waitress did you hear
the good news
bin Laden has been killed and she was
like um
I don't know I feel about that I mean
somebody's been and I'm like listen
bitch
you should rejoice yeah but this piece
of human garbage is gone and I rejoiced
I saw the news and I stood up in our
apartment and I cheered I saluted the
flag okay
and I said the Pledge of Allegiance my
thing is I can't
I don't ever sell abrade someone's death
right but I'm not knocking people that
are right now what I mean it's like hey
that's just how I feel you know that
that's just my feeling but I mean the
thing is I don't want to give a shit
what I like I'm dead better let's be
honest I think but yeah but it is it's
I'm not gonna knock people that I mean
it leave the flag why waving we're
number one out on the street and shit is
a little bit like much asking for
trouble - yeah alright so now all these
suicide bombers are like our leaders
dead I guess we could just do it now
yeah that's why yeah that's probably the
worst part about getting overexcited is
when then it can be used of fuel yeah
the other side yeah but I think I think
whether however you want to express it
is one thing yeah it's definitely
something that you can be like you know
it is a better place I feel like yeah
you know in the world yeah how long we
been trying to get this guy that's the
thing it's like it is mission
accomplished that was kind of like mmm
from the gecko when everything started
like well that's target number one yeah
yeah yeah and to be ten years crazy yeah
but I feel like the bigger story anyways
is just that how he could be living in
that house essentially five or six years
right and nobody knew it's without
internet yeah a house without internet
and they burn their trash with on the
yard in the compound uh-huh that even
things like they burn their garbage no
phone line no internet yeah I was saying
I mean I kind of tweeted this yesterday
but do you think like some old like Nick
Nolte type with a bunch of metals like
came out of retire
to get them
we need Malone column I'm retired
some guy that still comes in and beats
up whole SWAT teams like 76 with
emphysema a guy who actually confuses I
got no problem with him just cuz he's
colored
hey take it easy like he still talks
like that we don't mean a we don't mean
the president stop using that term
there's no smoking on this plane oh the
fake Osama photo the best thing about it
was his veneers look great take it back
to the dental yeah and you know what I
love is that he he used one of his wives
as a human shield back and forth about
definitely said that women were you this
is this is horrible yeah but this is a
joke you know some Road comic it's
probably gonna do or he's just like I
think is I guess that's the thing but
having all those wives I mean gotta be
honest right I mean one of them one of
you right away when you marry you're
like human shield I mean one of them
right you got the one you know the one
the tie right you got the one that's
like oh she cooks good other ones funny
maybe the fat one right Taman you miss
your big fat lady or abolition ever oh
wait you don't want to put out
they're on rotation oh my god
different days of the week different
ones are human she's deaf settle on
human shield can I say that his luxury
mansion yeah well it's kind of hard to
like shop around you know what I don't
understand I heard that they built that
mansion just for him
so they actually built it I guess before
he got there and then but there was
people there's a construction crew that
built it and they had to keep a secret I
guess dead there's a homeless guy in
front of our house that just rummages
through the trash and it's so bothersome
just to hear that right here
construction
what's going on over there is it I love
it there
could you imagine them having to order
internet though like if they did have
internet like the AT&T guy comes over
goes oh come on
this is bullshit to install Internet and
oh sorry
what do you think it's like to live on
the run though there's something I was
thinking about horrible like it's gotta
be just so much anxiety you ever had
like like someone suing you or you've
been arrested or whatever and you have a
court date pending oh yeah that's all
you can think about all the time because
you're just like because you just feel
like screwed you feel like you know
you're subject to the whims of other
people on a level you've never known
before yeah but like the out you know I
mean it's like if you're waiting for
like a court date and you could possibly
have to pay huge fine or have to do time
or whatever it's just like oh god that's
all you think about what have you done
brah it's like no I'm just saying I'm
just saying but like yeah oh oh with
like eight nine years ago I was I got
popped for DUI and I had to go back to
court a month later and they this thing
called the deferral program where if you
like if you didn't cause any property
damage I didn't hurt anybody and was
just you being a jerk and they pulled
you over like you can go through this
program it's like a couple months long
and then it gets expunged from your
record so that's what I did and it's one
of the things in my head though well
what if I get some a-hole prosecutor
that's just like no your honor I believe
we should make an example of this
so it's just variables when you're on
the run it has to be a constant
invariable
you just never know you know ice cream
truck coming down the street just cock
the gun right now that turn trying to
make your sandwich you expect me to turn
around with like this all the time all
the time oh that's why it's probably
it's the idea it's really people who do
that the best and like as being on the
run who stay gone for years and you like
had to do are like people that are
disconnected like Psychopaths associate
Rhee yeah I'm ready to go I'm ready hang
out wait to get down yeah yeah yeah
please come in blasting those guys know
they could stay like how do you lived in
the forest for six years yeah you know
what this reminds me of is that what mom
and I used to have this guy that would
drive us to and from the airport like a
car and he was an old man he was like in
his 70s and he had a little crack
problem just a little little bit of the
crack and I and I remember I asked him
what I'm like what's it like just smoked
crack like I just he's like well I mean
I smoked it and then I would just look
through I'd look through my people all
day just waiting for people to come and
you're like oh that sounds like the
worst fucked up looking through that
people that's the game man so the game
is be terrified what you were that day
you were you know a girl scout and
you're just going door to door Charles
sell some cookies
yeah dude open the door hey no you
didn't win I won because I saw you crack
he's waiting like if someone actually
knocked the door he would pull the door
off the hinges like like the Hulk
rip it clean off and would be like whoa
yeah I have a couple friends that tried
crack I never tried crack yeah I tried
it you did try it and is it like it
wasn't that big of a deal it was just
like I mean if you've done cocaine it
just was pretty much what it was it's
just like I just did cocaine no no like
I don't know a friend of mine told me he
was like its it was the it's the best
high ever so he was like immediately he
was like he's money out the window
so he wouldn't be able to buy again like
the turn he was like I just threw my
money away cuz I knew I wanted to go
back whoa oh yeah I'm surprised at you
guys actually by the way how the driver
was that like during the date when that
Driving Miss Daisy thing was popular and
everyone drivers parking sometimes
sometimes yeah when a drivers not high
on crack if you're going for if I'm
going for more than four days I'll get a
ride or get a service but like you got
this van so it's like red vans worse
I've been I've gone alright like went to
LAX it was like 5:00 in the morning and
then just oh why are we going by us
no no outside a dorm waiting so long for
this kiddy final runner oh hey sorry
guys still kind of drunk from the night
before
let me get my stuff it's like Oh college
kids price the worst super showers seven
other people they pick it out beside you
holy shit one of them really wants to
talk to you oh is that a coffee you're
trying to nap against the window and
yeah that happened when I flew into
Idaho to do a show up up there
and they had land on one of those little
commuter planes and we are in the the
baggage claim is not even a carousel
that runs
it's just they open a door and they take
the guy you see the baggage handlers
your bag and they do that and I'm
staying there waiting for my bag and
then they close it that's all the bags
you have so I a medium like fuck and
this guy who was on the flight he was
like sunglasses on he's like hey man
what's up I'm Andy right he's a
passenger and I was like what he's like
I'm Andy I'm like Tom and then I walked
past him I'm like who the fuck are you
but he wants to like talk I finally I
walk in they take me to like all of your
bag might have come earlier it turns out
it did so we grabbed the bag and I'm
like oh great and he's like you got your
bag I'm like this guy just wants to talk
to me yeah and then we get out to the
shuttle that takes us from the airport
to the thing he's like so I bet you glad
you have your bag I'm like yeah and he's
like so you wanted the text and I was
like no I'm not a tech he's like you're
not here for the shoot and I was like no
he's like oh I thought you were just a
dick because I introduced myself he
didn't really want to talk I thought you
were somebody with the photography group
here I was like no I'm not man but thank
you for but he introduced themselves to
me in an airport yeah yeah wait what are
you what are you selling I'm trying to
sell me sir yeah hey I'm Andy
well I can't yeah well I people look at
him way and they're like fuck that shit
but you know what's the worst thing when
you're on an airplane and then the
person next he'll the the 50 year old
house mom who's like what do you do and
you're like oh my Communion and then
it's just opening again you know who I
don't like there's always that one you
don't like the time you do like
yeah and like uh uh you know you should
I've got a friend yeah yeah you know I
don't you try to get on The Tonight Show
or what are you I've had people tell me
that I should I don't know I don't know
all right
oh my favorite is when they're like will
you just keep at that I don't work out
you're like no no it's already worked
out good I mean living yeah I'm fine I
just had somebody going that I knew from
college come to see me at a club and
after I got off they were talking me and
they go so you're gonna keep doing this
and they're like well you're gonna keep
doing this yeah I was like yeah that's
cool like I love that because it's like
it's like you say you want to leave and
be like hey man you know the bottoms
falling out right
there's no gold watch when you're 50
yeah whatever you're doing that you're
claiming is like a real quote-unquote
job it might not even be as real as mine
yeah yeah just telling you I mean I know
you got that thing where you think
there's no security in life there's none
yeah you know it's like it's like what
can you work in real estate or something
it's like that's somehow more secure or
something it's like oh man the rules
have changed
what is secure like dentistry huh am i
right
Matt you did wanted that one of my
favorite things ever you did IKEA
Heights yes is brilliant oh my god I
don't even know what it is yeah IKEA
Heights is a whole show that was filmed
inside the Burbank IKEA illegally
illegally those cameras that look like
just photography cameras but they film
oh yeah we did our scenes using their
furniture yeah and so it started out as
a soap opera on the first episode the
second episode they brought me in and it
became like like a almost a CSI oh my
ankle I play detective Mathis the
homicide detective of Ikea Heights and I
treat I treat it like it's just the
worst neighborhood ever good murder and
it is so brilliant and they usually end
with us getting thrown out like it'll be
let some of the acting and you'll just
hear someone go hey you can't film in
here and know this the person's necklace
break like the first look over on we're
not what we're just okay we'll leave and
see and by the fourth episode they
walked us out and they're all in walkie
talkies they're like yeah it's them yeah
from that show yeah yeah I keep what you
call IKEA Heights yeah it's all of them
really yeah I'm kicking them out right
now yeah yeah and see it's kind of like
like there's characters and they're just
getting in bed and they're just chugging
in a lot before you do this yeah we got
it down before you film it and for the
people listening it's I mean they're in
full costume with like fake beards and
they're getting into beds of Ikea acting
roles Alan that was that we shot that
one in the kitty furniture section so I
was especially like so what's this clip
like what is this oh this is where I'm
doing a voiceover it shows the people
that founded IKEA they're dressed like
pilgrims yeah that episode ends with me
getting tossed out it was a guy named
Dave Seeger he came up with it and then
Randall Park was also in it and yeah it
was it was fun but it was always like
nerve-wracking yeah we had whole teams
of people that would just distract IKEA
employees oh really like hey I need to
help and then get them out of the area
we needed to shoot in right because we
had like fight scenes and we had like.we
running around in there with guns and
like yeah like at one point oh oh they
did one we did one that the Halloween
episode where we just had people dressed
as zombies and go into Ikea and just
like they're zombies going all the way
through I can't uh and people were just
people like what the what's going on
and and yeah I don't know how to give
away but that's away is this all on
YouTube yeah that's all it's like seven
episodes Emily yeah for fun sorry or did
you funding to do it or is it under
no it is for channel 101 the best
websites ever had I love that shit but I
was actually scared watching it that's I
mean I mean just imagining not filming
it was insane because it's it's it's
crazy it's it's one of the best web
series I've seen in oh wow is that the
reason you guys just stopped it just
because it's chairing 101 or whatever or
is it you just got tired of getting
kicked out of we yeah it was we just
that that was the last one and and it
was yeah we just kind of done and we
were like either gonna have to start
doing it another IKEA but and the thing
is IKEA had a really good sense of humor
about it they're like you know we
actually enjoy it but they need to stop
like they were saying that and like
press releases like you need to cut it
out right and but yeah it was pretty
much if we did another one we probably
would've gotten arrested you know it
would have been fun I always thought
that maybe you guys could be like season
two you know where you're at Target or
something like yeah move to a different
name different neighborhood or something
like that
you ever see house of Cosby on Channel I
loved what they did and when it it
acceptable TV where they did Cosby's but
it would like with a gremlins oh yeah
Cosby like so so he's like no tomorrow's
like no Bill Cosby the comedian
entertainer it's satire just called it
out you can't sue us so stop sending us
letters yeah like what Saturday Night
Live does everybody
yeah it's called House of Cosby's yeah
it's still on YouTube I think I don't
know if it's yeah you can find that one
member one of the little Cosby's
bathtub cause we won't go in the
bathroom for the people that don't know
it's a whole cartoon based on just a
whole world of number one I'm clean up
like more and more retarded but then the
future Cosby came came out and was like
you have to keep making Cosby's hundred
Cosby is like always a genius crappy
like a levar burton cosby with the
little laser thing in his eyes yeah
number nine was naked and retarded on
first i can take up off tom is just
running we've met like the last three
years just watching yeah every now and
then you go back to this this in the
tiny hat sketch from Tim and Eric have
you ever seen that you know I heard
somebody recently well there's a
Saturday Night Live skit with tiny hat
yeah there was a big deal about that
but you know what it's our night
lifesteal shit all the time really yeah
what they have right so much writers
that I heard that I mean there's been so
many skits that people are like what the
fuck siren I live just jacked my shit
again and it's just because all these
writers Theo and Rudy have become part
of our lexicon that's correct because
before there was mommy
there was Rudy Anthea yeah yeah we even
wanted to name a couple of dogs
Oh Andy are not any John Daly's Bukowski
Bukowski
Billy Bukowski Cosby I'm fucking it up
bill because bill Bukowski's yelled the
cows he does a combination of Bukowski
and Bill Cosby yeah who does Jon Daly he
does like seems like pudding like a
jello pudding poems or as I call him
Jones and he doesn't like it so like
with Rudy Camille where is my
motherfucking coke coke makes her smile
I mean the coke go motherfucker so he'd
like it'll just trail off in a fucking
vial Bukowski shit cuz the car shut down
House of Cosby's yeah yeah that's
amazing I could do anything you know and
actually that letter the letter from the
lawyer I remember it was available
somewhere and back then it was like this
disturbing and disgusting portrayal of
Cosby oh they were really upset about
who's naked right there
remember that clip you found and Bill
Cosby doing like the Monday Night
Football
oh my god I put that on my website a
long time there's that he was actually
doing he does a guest appearance on a
college football game and they're just
they talking about the game and he does
the intro but he tries to do an
old-school like 1940s intro to players
where they would say you know the name
and then like trumpets would play but he
does it all Cosby so he's just like
playing it just looks like a man and one
of his eyes is totally wonky now like
he's got crazy Cosby eyes he does he has
Forest Whitaker eyes yes oh poor guys
yeah I saw him in in Las Vegas that's
past November but yeah I was you know I
was nowhere near him oh yeah way up in
the nosebleed seats but was he awesome
it's awesome he's great yeah great he
was still good yeah I was just two hours
of hilarious mister I would love ya just
telling a story yet is sitting in a
chair he's rambling time I like like you
don't hit told some old
I could watch that for hours hey you saw
an awesome show this weekend didn't you
I did it's been seeing Prince lately
it's actually really good right online I
like all of this it's a forum it's super
ghetto it's super crap it's like yeah
it's an Inglewood it's not Saturday you
know but it but the actual amphitheater
is like a small or amphitheater huh so
like watching a show there especially
watching his thing where he's basically
in the round yes yeah he'll start
playing one song and then halfway
through like like please play the song
looks like on piano by himself and then
he stopped and was like took the mic
we're like hey what should I do now and
so many others was like why would your
girlfriend he's like girlfriend I just
do it right into the song yeah really
yeah like just pop my band I will play
any song we feel like at that moment
that's great and he's like oh he's did
some more music he's like oh you want to
sing and it would bring some woman on
stage and I'm like no no like yelling
like me no can hear me but yeah turns
out oh it's Gwen Stefani you pulled a
fast one on me friends yeah did you do
Purple Rain era which is like the best
because can I tell you what I really
hate France went downhill for me when it
was the D to the ad they didn't do it
seem like the newest thing they did was
like cream to tell you the truth because
I have the cream get on top let's grow
up I prefer that
so bad I like I'm personally at the
Purple Rain and then the Jaguar song
yeah well he did see it he doesn't do
any filthy stuff anymore like Jack you
off her head Nikki but at one point it
started playing darling Eddy in MIDI
darling Nikki and people started sharing
and he's like y'all ought to be ashamed
and we all laughed
they're like buddy I mean right if I was
your girlfriend probably my favorite
print song was your girlfriend yeah
Paisley Park yeah it's before Purple
Rain okay I think anyway
but yeah like all that era was awesome
but he did like all the like the Purple
Rain stuff and like and he just keeps
doing on course did he do uh would that
for you and they do the for you I think
we did that song yeah I always thought
that French would have dry elbows yeah
it seems like you would have ashy elbows
he has Little Boots this is that song if
I was your girlfriend ah for this part
to get over here
yep miss pac-man yeah yeah see it's
kiddie sounds like I like when he's just
like a sex alien yeah somebody said
somebody said was like oh my god did you
walk in his hands it's like no it was
like yeah he I'm sure I saw he walked in
his hands all over this day I'll pull up
I'll turn my phone off I'll show you the
picture state is ridicu so let's say the
stage is that print symbol and he just
walks all over it yeah and we just do
like guitar so such an amazing guitar
player he do that he doesn't do that
shit anymore of the artist formerly
known as right now we need to come up
with comedian names like oh oh you know
Welles came out Sheila E came out did
glamorous life it tore the roof off like
she kind of didn't steal the show but
everyone was like that's exactly the
song I want to hear right now I want to
watch you hang on those drums and she
didn't like a silver evening gown just
whacking all these drums standing in the
middle of the cymbal oh my god is this
something that he's doing now all the
time yeah it's like a residency because
he just he doesn't have a middle man
it's just him in the forum so it's like
uh tickets are twenty five to like a
hundred bucks yeah I think I went with
Kara took me a year our friend Kara took
me and she got like the I think like a
50-buck tickets or something like that
just unreal
really yeah wait I show you just mix it
on mushrooms yeah I was kind of I was
pounding beers I was kind of wishing I
was hi yeah cuz it was just like that's
a few of the Pixies were they playing
troubadour no that place it it's gonna
be a horrible fire hazard
what is a weight well they're touring
like they're in Canada right now so I
don't think they have LA dates yet but I
saw them last I see them every time they
come out and I nerd out hard
you ever see ween life no that's a fun I
love seeing life yeah it's fucking good
stuff
it's like I don't know if you know if we
listened to wheen at all but their
concerts are pretty it's kind of like
mixing like a jam band with ween their
live show you know who I miss John
Spencer fucking I'm sure he's still
around okay I see the picture now oh
yeah it's like that symbol mm-hmm what
is a symbol it's like an ankh it's like
a penis email sign in the mail sign and
he needs a flashlight but like with no
hole he's amazing
ya know it heals the whole time yeah I
you see what you're doing a dance in
heels I had a friend of a friend meet
Prince and and go backstage let me guess
he was a dick no it's it's well yeah
well so okay so they get they get to his
bedroom his hotel whatever and he takes
off his purple pants and he takes off
his purple shirt and he gets down to his
purple panties and purple socks and she
was like all right that's enough like
the fact that the panties and the socks
everything was purple I can't do it yes
your friend was gonna do it with Prince
yeah whoa it was like too much purple
and she was like I can't oh wow fuck you
not a purple yeah he's got a lot of a
knows how to make love to Purple Rain
chick jumped in the lake and it wasn't
the wrong Lake Prince she's naked and
freezing I saw titties in a movie it was
Purple Rain and it was so sexual
yeah that blew my mind dude
no remember all those old 80s movies
that that was like the first time to see
boobs like what was a hot dog hot dog
probably like eight times yeah my friend
had it on VHS we just watch it like
we're so stupid
yeah it's better like a country bully
that goes to compete in a ski off and
there's like evil German skiers mimicked
it in Hot Tub Time Machine I think a
little yeah guys
yeah there was a lot of those movies
what was another one there's there's
ones that were like they were like okay
like the John Hughes stuff and like
better off dead we just like oh these
are good movies and these are funny yeah
funny and tough and they're ones they're
just like meat tips that's all they're
about Porky's pork
Porky's is like number one right hotdog
loose screws yeah
they were all like based off the Yankees
like what else can we get chicks are for
fuckin that was one of my favorite
movies to this day is Revenge of the
Nerds that's great it's still so goddamn
funny yeah it's all good perfectly made
common bugger
everything is pressed for all the
characters yeah I always thought they
should cross we've been to the nerds and
police academy have a crossover baby why
didn't they do that awesome you know
someone pitched that and people were
just like nah my property that's yours
booger won't work with whatever the
whole thing in the balls and everybody
no dice Steve Guttenberg nobody would
hold out for the booger Bob
and I I was in how was it a storytelling
show with the last sketch fest in San
Francisco with the purple onion and
Bobcat Goldthwait wanted people on it
and his stories were just amazing really
yeah because he used to like open for
nirvana like all these crazy ass stories
likes their stories about him talking
with Kurt Cobain and how funny Kurt
Cobain was and really yeah crazy
I met Kurt once did did you really first
I'm tripping on acid and Dayton Ohio
whoa I went with this girl I think it
was eighteen nineteen and never tried
asked it before it's fucking great time
but the opening band was on it was like
this asian band that they just came out
on stage and screen the whole time like
it was not even music what the fuck is
this shit
remember zone an eye for loudness and so
I'm sitting like the site of stage
watching the opening band kind of like
right in front of the mosh pit and the
Kurt just was standing right next to me
I said what the fuck you know I look
over and I'm like my shirt ripping on
this you know he's eating Cheetos and he
just goes to the main Cheetos okay and I
took a cheeto and I'm like oh thanks and
something something goes Oh Kurt and
then he just throws the bag of Cheetos
to everyone but I put that cheeto in my
pocket I got all about it later and
looked in my pockets all fucked up but I
was gonna go to the store buy a new one
you know this is it's amazing Kurt
Cobain gave you a cheeto that was the
dumbest night ever first time tripping
on the way back we're having sex while
driving during a thunderstorm like the
girl driving yeah are you and she's like
sitting on me like this way she was a
really small small girl oh and she was
like sitting on me that way and her legs
are on each side and she's just like
fucking me and I remember it's America
we make it out of our adolescence I know
during a thunderstorm during a
thunderstorm it was a luckily was a
station where I can sit one has long
seats you know where it's like okay in
the couch seat have couches and cars
more often they don't do that man
I met Susie sewon's how was her teeth
Susie's great teeth oh I can recommend
she has any no we we uh we have to ask
you have to get out of here we know
whatever you guys want no that's fine we
know you have anything you want to share
don't oh just locked picture I don't
know if we could talk about how my
violet I don't know
so it's why she's very exciting we're
now we're now gonna okay so Matt just
wrote and shot a pilot and now you're
handing it over work we'll be handing it
over next week this is very exciting at
all about what your pilot's about yeah
sure it basically uh I work with comedy
side I'd already pitched some things
Comedy Central and they were kinda like
what would your show be about if you had
a show and you were starring in it would
be about and so I basically made it
about me doing my old job which was
closed captioning for the hearing
impaired editor basically like a caption
editor yeah it was kind of like you know
not any advancement but it kept me
afloat yeah you know and so I made this
guy not a comedian because I don't think
people really want I think Louise done
it here I mean it's like between
Seinfeld and Louie it's like Louise
Louise taking it as far as it's gonna go
in perfect yeah it means I don't want to
come out and have a shoulder I'm a
comedian tits like who cares so he's
like in every man and he's got a
curmudgeonly best friend played by Kyle
Kinane and so we kind of just go on
adventures and it's almost it's almost
like a Ren and Stimpy dynamic ish
because we go back and forth with me and
especially in this episode I'm it wasn't
a pilot I I find this record album that
I that I loved as a kid and I'm getting
hammered at a record store at night with
a bunch of people and this guy's like
well I'll give you this but you got to
be at this club by the certain time you
should write this down and like I'm
gonna remember it I wake up
hungover don't remember anything go to
work and I have to piece together you
know the what so and Kyle
I go out and and and we're chasing a
record album so it's kind of like
ideally every episode be kind like a
little mission ya know and it kind of
has it has it kind of has that that It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia feel if I
could compare it to anything it wouldn't
be like that show but it'd be similar in
terms of like the look and feel of that
so yeah so I wrote it with Brent
Forrester who is a writer and producer
on the office and so we yeah we just
finished I mean editing and all that
jazz and so now we're gonna do color
correction and do the final sound mix
and then turn it in and they'll do
they'll do a couple screenings in like
Vegas and then a little couple for the
kind of central people and I don't know
when we'll know but I'm just really
excited about just being totally done
with it feeling of having it out of your
own hands it's an awesome
he'll be fine either way yes or no but
like you know it's so great I cannot
wait to see this um what how about like
when you you told them what your show
would be about did you then write like a
draft or did you meet up with the was
your writing partner Brent Brent how did
you go about like creating it we wrote
um we we just wrote a bunch of notes for
when we pitched it mm-hmm I don't I
don't know if we actually left anything
behind in terms of like here's something
for you to read but we did once we once
we had written a script and gone through
a couple drafts that we really liked
then we turn that in because the cool
thing about this is they they gave us a
deal where they just gave us enough
money to shoot it ourselves so we shot
it ourselves oh great Brent directed it
we produced it some cast at all all that
jazz so it basically was like a
presentation pilot but we also kept them
in the loop on oh here's the script -
yeah there's no if this fly just because
I felt like we just turned the script in
and I knew I was gonna put all these
funny people in it you blew read the
script be like I don't know if I if I
really understand and relate it to it so
it's so you know it was cool that they
were just like they made us halfway
there like oh yeah just want you to
shoot it then yeah that's also have
something to show people you got to do
something you really wanted to yeah or
make exactly that's so great I can't
wait to see this yeah yeah I'll
definitely show it to you guys and a
knows what are you if anyone wants to
see you they can go to Chicago Matt
Braunger com
that's not be in Denver Denver improv
and next neck weekend after this one so
neck all right
Denver's a great city man yeah I love I
love Colorado so Denver peeps go see
Matt Braunger yeah dumb Brown problem
yeah and he spells last name BR aun ger
that is correct H I TR cont cont and
where are we gonna be mommy this week we
will be at the Fort Lauderdale improv
the two mommies for the price of what
you guys seldom do it at the Seminole
Hard Rock ooh which is actually in
Hollywood Florida I believe and right
beer man I'm not doing anything I'm just
doing tons of podcasts trying to get my
computer fixed awesome go to death squad
TV to download all the video components
to all these podcasts don't forget to
subscribe to us on iTunes under death
squad and listen to us on stitcher radio